[Music]
so who in the audience would describe
themselves as developers or computer
engineers with a new skill set in
machine learning quite a few that's a
good thing
and I would like to share with you a
couple of tools that you can use
day-to-day to work faster and more
efficiently TP use is of course one of
them but there will be a couple of
others so this is a GPU v2 this is a GPU
v3 those are fairly large boards it's
like this roughly and each one of those
boards has four chips each chip is a
dual-core chip and those accelerators
are designed specifically to accelerate
machine learning workloads you can get
them as boards like this you can also
give them as a full rack it's called a
pod and the trick is that in Iraq all
the GPUs are interconnected or a
high-performance interconnect which
makes them look like a single
accelerator to your workload so you
don't have to handle complicated
distribution code the only thing you do
is you increase your batch size to work
on those bigger machines and just a
couple of words of what makes them
special inside of a GPU so aboard for
chips eight cores in each one of those
cores you have two things one is a
fairly traditional vector processing
unit so that's a vector processor and
the second one that is what makes this
special for machine learning is a matrix
multiply unit so there is a special
species specific units Hardware unit
that is dedicated to performing 128 by
128 matrix multiplications in reduced
precision in a format called B float16
and machine learning workloads are full
of matrix multiple is non
multiplications so by having this
dedicated Hardware in there this is what
accelerates machine learning workload
specifically
now about this precision so using
reduced precision is a fairly common
trick in in in machine learning usually
you do so in float16
the standard flow 16 precision but as
you see here flow 16 has only 5 exponent
bits so fewer than float32
which means that when you reduce the
precision sometimes you get under flows
or overflows and you have to do
additional work on your model to
overcome that it's not necessarily
complicated but it's work and so what we
did in Tipu's is that we use the
slightly different 16-bit format called
b float 16 and you see it has exactly
the same number of ex of exponent bits
then float 32 just the end result is cut
offs or a use precision but exactly the
same range
so usually default 16 is a drop-in
replacement for 4 float 32 in neural
network workloads and also we do the
multiplications 16-bit x 16-bit which
gives you the 32-bit results and we keep
this 32-bit results and finally the way
it's architected is that we have so try
to remember from your calculus courses
how to perform a matrix multiplication
each result is a dot product of one line
of one matrix and one column of the
second Matrix and a dot product is a
series of multiply and accumulate
operations multiplied plus multiply plus
x so that's why the unit component of
this array is a multiplied accumulator
and by having 120 by 128 multiply
accumulators connecting like this i'm
not expecting you to understand this
animation immediately you will have to
spend a little bit more time on it I
guess but the idea is that you load one
matrix into the array the other matrix
the values they flow through the erase
all the intermediate sums
they flow through the array in this
direction and what comes out from this
end or your final dot dot products of
the resulting matrix
so it's a one-pass operation no memory
access while you're doing this no
writing to registers an intermediate
some and reading it back which is why
it's fast and the the second advantage
is that the unit of processing the
16-bit by 16-bit to 32-bit multiply
accumulate it's a 20 piece of hardware
it's not a full processor that can do
anything it's just a multiply
accumulator and that's why we can cram a
huge number of them in each GPU each GPU
core 120 by 128
16 thousand of those multiplied
accumulate compute units and of course
GPU is dual core so thirty-two thousand
in total and this is the architecture so
specifically for matrix multiplications
that gives TP use an edge in terms of
density density means power and power
means cost a rough idea of the cost some
people might have seen my talk from last
year about building this model and I'm
using this model as a benchmark these
days so this model trains in four and a
half hours on a GPU and if I provision
five GPUs in a cluster I can train it in
one hour and I chose this example
because I can train it in one hour also
on a GPU v2 so the rough idea is this 14
board is roughly equivalent to five of
the biggest GPUs that we have in terms
of speed and in terms of cost is roughly
five three times cheaper so I could go
on forever and bore you to death with
all the technical details and if you ask
me questions I will but this is the dev
zone so you want to see code so let's
get code on the screen I will be I love
notebooks I will be using notebooks and
by the way have you seen that in ml
engine there is this new notebook
instances button where you can provision
a new instance already set up for
tensorflow or PI torch with the GPU and
also I set one up with a teepee
so the what you get is a link that opens
Jupiter lab actually I had it open
already that's why this is it's doing
this so let's go in my instance here and
before we start using GPUs I have to
tell you a couple of things about data
how to load data because TP news are
very very fast accelerators and the
first problem you're going to encounter
with GPUs is not being able to feed them
data quick enough so let's talk about
data in this I will be working with a
data set on this model
it's a detection data set of wildlife
photography so you see my classes coming
up in this in this notebook goldfish
shark and so on but that's those are
built the metadata what I want to show
you is how I load my images so here is I
will be using the TF the data dot data
set API and that's an API that is
designed to prepare data sets for
training so it has all the natural
function calls that you need for
repeating across multiple epochs
batching shuffling and so on how does it
work
so the first line here is list files I
give it a folder and I obtain a data set
of file names then the API allows me to
map any function on that data set here
I'm mapping a decoding function this
function which has imaged that decode
JPEG and read file before it so now I
have a date from my data set of file
names I have a data set of images then I
need to resize and Pat them so I map
this function which is just resizing and
then I repeat I can shuffle it I batch
it into by 16 and the API also this is
interesting the prefetch a call you can
use this to tell tensorflow to prefetch
the next batch while it is training on
the current batch
so let's try let's try to run this how
do I iterate on a data set in tensor
flow well now you can do for images in
data set just a normal loop this only
works in eager mode
I'm intentional eager motion so you see
I'm just displaying here the shape of my
tensor batches of 16 images of 384 by
384 and it's painfully slow it's
horrible
I wait seconds for 16 images to come up
why is that well the reason is that I'm
reading for GCSE Google Cloud storage
which is a good thing from GCSE you can
get a crazy throughput but GCS is a
storage that is attached through IP the
internet and it has a per file penalty
this data set has 300,000 images you
will not load an image by image that
does not work so what is the the right
way of doing it the correct way is to
batch your images into some file format
that can contain multiple pieces of data
at once some kind of record file format
in tensorflow you usually use the TF
record file format but really it has
nothing specific special about it it's
just a file format to cram multiple
pieces of information in one file with
tags so how does this work now again TF
the data that the data set list files I
have a data set of file names this time
I have done the pre-processing of my
files so I'm reading from a different
folder that has these TF record files
then I instantiate from that TF record
data set so now I have a data set of
records you have noticed that I'm
actually doing it through this interleaf
function because this is how I can read
from 16 different files at the same time
and that's how you get the throughput
you back your images into big files 100
megabytes TF record files and then read
from 16 of them at the same
and then map repeat and everything else
let me show you that and of course the
decoding function here is this function
where I simply unpack what I put in my
data set so what I put in my TF records
is the image so metadata and since this
was a detection beta the data said I
have the bounding boxes and the classes
of this data so yeah it has displayed it
it is a data set detection a data set
you can see ladybugs dolphins and so on
and this time well look this time my
images are coming out sixteen by sixteen
are aesthetically so this is what you
should do when reading from well when
packaging data for consumption by
training and especially for GPUs so now
let's get training we have already our
data set lets get trained i'm switching
here to a different notebook technology
which you might know this is
collaboratory that's a free service on
google when you get notebooks with a
free back-end and actually if I click
run time here change run time type I can
get a TPU accelerator for free I love it
so this is a slightly different data
search but not very different let me do
this TPU detection it says read running
on TPU configuration let me show what
I'm here as well I'm loading from a TF
record data set but let me show you what
what this data set is it's a data set of
images so we will be classifying flowers
here and you recognize the familiar data
set API I hope by now it's familiar with
data set dot map don't repeat to the
batch but prefetch and so on so this is
how I create my data set but now and I'm
working in chaos so I hope most of you
recognize
this kind of chaos code what do you have
a sequential model and a bunch of layers
the three lines of code I would like to
attract your attention to are these
three this is how you train a Kaos model
on TPU one line to find a TPU the second
line to define a TPU distribution
strategy using that GPU and a third line
to transform your model into a TPU model
from there on you train it as you
normally would in chaos so let me launch
the training here you see I'm doing TPU
model dot Fit passing the data set and
what is going on is interesting you see
compiling actually what is going on my
code is running on a VM a normal VM the
TPU is attached through the network to
it tensorflow
defines my model as a computation graph
and it's that computation graph that is
shipped off to the remote GPU for
training and from that computation graph
we use Excel a the accelerated linear
algebra compiler to compile that graph
into GPU microcode so the tip you never
see is your Python code you have to be
on there in mind it only sees your your
graph but if you use the data the data
keep data did as an API your data
pipeline is also packaged as part of
this graph so the GPU will be pulling
data directly from GCS which is very
efficient and as you said I can see here
this is what I love about GPUs on small
to medium models I can get training
times of 4 seconds per epoch and I can
iterate in minutes interactively in a
notebook on on various models this is a
smaller model this one has three
thousand images but you see it's already
trained 15 epochs we will see if it's
trained well yep here is the accuracy
fine it got to 75% and let
run a couple of predictions from it see
if it is classifying my flowers
correctly running displaying here we go
so it doesn't get all of them right
but the dandelion is fine the roses the
sunflowers dandelion and it missed it
well this is a hard one
all right you've got a couple of
mistakes no more always perfect but this
is what I love about GPUs it's really
fast and you can use it use them
interactively but now I want to show you
a bigger model a bigger one and for this
of course a bigger model that will be
training in half an hour that is not
something that you would be comfortable
doing in your notebook I mean doing
interactively on a machine you don't
want to be paying for an expensive
machine to type code if that is only
when you do interactive work I want to
be I want something that allows me to
take a notebook and launch it as a job
on hardware that we will be provision
just for that job and decommission when
the job is finished
that is the fearing API so that's a new
thing reminder the three lines to get a
carets model on a GPU the couple of
lines to load TF record data such using
interleaved to read read from sixteen
different files at once but the last
thing that I want to show you is a new
API called ferry so let me show you the
code I'm back into my previous notebook
for with the detection model and now the
fearing API is just this it has three
lines first set builder to say to say
something about my environment I have
actually built my dependencies as a
docker container that's a couple of
lines I just I just have a couple of big
dependencies the second one which says
where are you deploying I'm deploying to
GCP which is ml engine and this is the
hardware configuration I want I actually
want to plow TPU b3 to be provisioned
for this job and destroyed after the job
and finally what am i deploying I'm
deploying a full notebook this is a
notebook friendly API I have the the
name of my notebook and I have a couple
of sidecar files which I listed behind
it now when I launch this it will build
all of those things into another
document container I don't have to know
about docker it does it and launch a job
on email engine which I think we will
see here let us go to jobs on ml engine
and write I have two jobs running this
is a new one has been running for 18
seconds and I actually wanted to train
this big model here with you on stage in
20 minutes it was a bit tough you will
have to come to my repeat session
tomorrow to see this model actually
built on stage so I started at UC 37
minutes ago that's the second job just
before I stepped on stage and let me see
if it has finished well it looks like
yeah it looks like we have a model it's
here where did I I just lost it it's
this one let me open it open this file
downloads alright still downloading okay
come on download the interlace is slow
here so it will be downloading and INRIA
loading the the uploading is the
bottleneck here and not the training but
the result is actually a notebook that
is what I was saying about a notebook
friendly API I like working on notebook
in notebooks because I can do data
preparation and visually eyeball my data
set I can have my training cell then I
can play with the train model and
visually eyeball that is doing the right
thing all that in a notebook that is
what I use what I do interactive work in
a notebook but then when I launched all
that as a job I don't want to lose all
of that so here will this API still
downloading and then it
we'll be uploading sorry I will cheat
and actually show you results from a
previous run because we are running out
of time but here with this API I can
have all that as a job and the result of
the job of course is the saved model in
the bucket where I told it to save my
model and so on but it's also a fully
rendered notebook where I have all my
cells rendered and I can eyeball
anything all the graphs all the
visualizations that I have put in there
[Music]